[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  mom Who am I you are a gift  we believe that you came here for a  reason  I know it's been difficult for you  lately but you feel different from other  kids  [Music]  Kaitlin commander he's a creep help me  Mom I want him in handcuffs  I know what I'm going do you even know  who is real lovers i miss your mother  let's go  maybe there is - mama brandy  never turn against ourselves he's not  some hey who's messing with me  [Applause]  something wrong go around by chance  one of the only people in the world that  knows how special I am they are believed  to be no survivors among the 268  passengers on board I know there is good  inside you  [Music]  I wanted you good man  I do  [Music]